mais n'ont pas besoin de mettre de
costumes aujourd'hui
je pense
on aujourd'hui dans les locaux de team
head start up française monde connecté
pour les enfants alors on va pas du tout
pareil monde connecté pour les enfants
mais bon on fait faire un petit coucou y
ait du monde dans ses bureaux on
connaissait déjà stéphane savoie ces
femmes d'accord stéphane c'est le boss a
déjà une fois avec moi
voilà y'a bilal ça va enfin pourvu que
ça va les gars ça va ça bosse c'est
sérieux ça c'est flou que le patient
fois cent fois les caméras tout nous
connecter tout ça va ça bosse dur là ça
va ça va ça va ça va bon il ya plein de
monde ici ce monde est sérieux alors
aujourd'hui enfin du tout par les deux
mondes connectés pour enfants on
pourrait mais n'ont d'ailleurs à des sas
et on en parle à une prochaine frappe en
avant la voix du nord aujourd'hui je
vous parlais d'un logiciel très pratique
il faut permettre de récupérer les
données que vous avez passé par erreur
sur votre ordinateur
hyper cool
[Musique]
stéphane ça va bonjour bonjour maman
gens peuvent pas me regarder tu vas
chercher quoi
alors aujourd'hui vous parler d'une
solution qui va vous aider si vous avez
effacé vos données sur votre ordinateur
je sais pas si ça vous est déjà arrivé
ça m'est déjà arrivé et franchement ça
fout franchement les boules alors l'idée
c'est vous présentez un logiciel qui
s'appelle orco bri
je vous l'avais déjà présenté il ya
quelques temps c'est un logiciel payant
est aujourd'hui à la version gratuite
un logiciel édité par dwan de recherche
dans command leur chair est venu me voir
monsieur heureux
cette botte de faire une vidéo sponsos
en auto logiciels gratuits j'ai dit ça
me botte déjà ça me permet de rentrer un
peu d'argent pour faire évoluer les
lâcher donc ça c'est plutôt cool
et puis le deuxième point qui
franchement intéressant c'est pouvoir
vous donner un bon plan un bon tuyau
pour tester ce logiciel qui est gratuit
alors gratuit jusqu'à 100 légal et pour
récupérer la photo de votre grand mère
vous avez faceo alors vos données
bancaires confidentielles
c'est très intéressant ce que je vous
propose c'est je me mets sur mon ordi je
vous montre comment ça marche et après
je vous invite franchement essayer parce
que vous verrez que ça peut franchement
vous sauver la vie je sais pas si ça
vous est déjà arrivé vous d'avoir des
données comme ça que vous fassiez après
vous arracher les cheveux chercher tous
les logiciels j'achète tous les côtés
pour savoir comment vous récupérez
redonner d'ailleurs si vous est déjà
arrivé
vous marquez tout ça on va en
commentaire on va sans le redis on
regarde ça et après vous vous dites ce
que vous en pensez en bas tu son disque
dur externe
j'ai mis une petite photo de moi un bal
avec ma petite tronche qui est juste là
haut up ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on va aller faire un petit tour de
recovery qui doit être quelque part dans
toutes vos applications ici on l'a on
louvre ils me demandent un code parce
qu'il veut modifier les choses dans leur
corps et vous avez pas mal de
possibilités récupération de fichiers
supprimés ça peut être intéressant sur
la suppression accidentelle panne de
courant
récupération de corbeil nous c'est ce
qu'on va regarder on a une corbeille
vidéo veut récupérer ça c'est
franchement intéressante récupération
disques formatés récupération de
partitions perdu universel enfin ya pas
mal de choses ça logiciel qui est
compliqué à thala sans qui je vous le
dis pour le coup intéressant parce qu'il
est en version gratuite
ça c'est franchement hyper cool alors
récupération de corps veille on va déjà
commencer par prendre un petit fichier
qui est là hop petits fichiers clic
droit placé dans la corbeille paf
bisous au revoir je vais dans la
corbeille je vide la corbeille et hop
nos photos s'en va voilà c'est terminé
bisous voilà et là franchement chaque
grosse grosse galère je vous dit comment
je vais faire et bien fait tout
simplement dans récupération de corbeil
jeu clé
dessus et là il fait une analyse alors
on va attendre quelques instants vous
allez voir c'est franchement intéressant
l'analyse est terminée ok donc là je
vois bien trash mais accents vous avez
vu hop je clique je re clic est là qu
est ce que je vois ma fameuse photo qui
récupère et sur mon disque là mon disque
externe vous pouvez le faire sur votre
disque externe ou pouvait le faire sur
votre disque enfin sur ce que vous
voulez sur une clé usb c'est franchement
ita pratique vous cliquez sur récupérer
version gratuite claque récupérer et là
je l'année où je veux pour me remettre
typiquement là où il était je mets là
j'enregistre sale récupère et je reviens
ensuite directement sur mon disque dur
qui est là haut up paf recovery team a
créé un petit dossier
monti backup trash tac et ma photo et la
mort hier j'espère cette astuce vous
aura été personnellement logiciel je
trouve franchement cool très intéressant
je vous invite à essayer car son
graphique homs au moins vous en
profiterez dites moi tout ce que vous en
pensez en bons commentaires restez
connectés je vous invite à regarder
plein de vidéos comme ça vous saurez
tout découvrir les nouveaux smartphones
du moment les nouveaux ordi plein de
choses c'est franchement hyper cool
voilà où nous embrasse foyer ça a bien
d'autres